thanks to market volatility societal
strife at home and abroad
many people are turning to an age-old
investment that's supposedly
rock solid that's right gold
now you may have seen an ad like this
one or a thousand times on cable tv
that's why i'm going to do two things
support our military
and buy gold from roslin capital you
need to protect yourself in today's
economy when people start talking to you
about the advantages of buying gold you
might rightfully suspect that they're
trying to sell you some gold but what
we're really here to find out is
is gold a good investment and should i
buy it off an
ad on tv
[Music]
to tell the whole story of gold we gotta
go way
back humanity's love affair with gold
dates back many millennia
and is unique in its globe spanning
popularity both the inca
and egyptian empires two societies that
never knew about each other
believed it to be from the bodies of the
gods themselves but for most of its
history up until very recently
there was no concept of gold as
something with a fluctuating price or an
investment
gold didn't cost money it was money then
something changed well even now gold a
lot of people would say doesn't have any
return
it doesn't you know there is no uh
interest paid on gold there's no coupon
there's no dividend
um in a sense it has a return and the
price can go up but the price can go
down as well
but through most of history that was not
the case it was a
it was an asset with no with no risk it
was an exchange
at a fixed price uh to the to the
currency
so there was no risk in that asset but
there was no return either
and that's really that you know that's
the historic reason for investing in
gold
up until the 1970s when of course uh
richard nixon
leaves the goal takes the usd off the
gold standard gold
overnight goes from 35 uh to
many times that amount but the capital
gain that you got on gold if you
bought it in 1972 and held 1980 was you
know one of the great rallies in history
but think about the what's changed to
the previous thing previously
it was a instrument with no risk and no
return now it's got
a stupendous return but it's also got a
substantial risk
um because if you then bought it in 1980
the price
slid through the 80s um and continued to
slide and slide and slide
until it was i think under 500 an ounce
so should people be
investing in gold one good reason why
you probably do want to hold a little
bit of gold in your portfolio which is
that
it behaves differently to everything
else that you've got pretty much
if the stock market crashes you know
when people sell their stocks and
squeeze out of that they'll some of it
will go into cash
but some of it will go into gold and you
only need a very small amount of that
investment to push into gold to really
push the price up quite substantially
and how much gold should one person have
a lot of investment advisors would say
that you should um
you know you should have gold at about
say two percent or so of your equity
of your overall portfolio all right i
want to buy some gold
how do i do it easily my personal advice
would be then you may as well just go
the simplest method
and trust that it'll prove okay and at
the moment i would say that's probably
an etf etfs like the spdr gold trust
ticker symbol gld offer shares backed by
physical gold bars in bank vaults around
the world
and those shares trade just like stocks
now i could invest in an etf that goes
up or down with the price of gold but
heck gold looks cool
i want to hold it in my hand what's the
easiest way for someone to buy
physical gold here in the united states
the easiest way for most
investors to get into physical gold that
means owning
a piece of gold is to buy gold bullion
coins
what many americans might not be aware
of is the
united states government in 1986
authorized the mint to start making
uh american gold bullion coins and i
have a sample here
so this is what it looks like so
right there it is so yeah this is a one
ounce gold coin
it's called the american eagle gold
uh it is the most popular gold bullion
coin in the world outstripping the
cougar and
the mint doesn't have the ability to
create a two-way market
so what they end up doing is they sell
it to a group of what we call
authorized purchasers which guarantee
to buy the gold back if you want to sell
it back at whatever the market price is
all you have to do is go right to the
mint's website
and list the authorized purchasers and
those authorized purchasers
not only sell that directly to
individuals
but they also sell it as a wholesaler
to other retailers it should be
mentioned that the u.s mint isn't the
only name in the game when it comes to
gold coins
mints around the world offer coins for
investment or collection
but before i finish up with ed i had to
ask one question
what does fort knox look like
i could tell you but i'd have to kill
you henry
you can't talk gold without talking
about fort knox
the united states bullion depository is
the single largest gold vault in the
world
and it hasn't been opened to the media
since 1974.
here they do a routine job routinely and
what glamour there is
comes from what they're guarding a vast
amount of gold
inside its walls sit more than 147
million ounces of gold
there's a lot of gold at fort knox uh
you've never seen
as much gold as yours and fort knox
because the united states has the
largest gold reserves
in the world by a factor of three it's
incredible to be around that much gold
in in just such a small space take a
look at youtube and you'll see no
shortage of collectors
or as they call themselves stackers who
keep their precious metals on site
why do they do it i talked with the
owner of the account silver bean counter
to find out
he wasn't willing to show his face but
you'd probably value your privacy too if
you had tens of thousands of dollars of
gold coins in your house
this is a 1924 american gold eagle right
here
this is a south african krugerrand
australian kangaroo yes
you know the big reasons people purchase
precious metals in the first places it's
it's really untraceable very common
um governments businesses don't know
that you have it
so it's a good way to store wealth in a
very private way i
keep it all in a spreadsheet so i have a
running total i know
exactly what i spent on something when i
bought it what the spot price
of the precious metal was at the time
whether or not it's gold or silver
and then of course the current value of
it i track that as well
stacking is basically purchasing of
precious metals
on a regular basis whether or not you do
it weekly with each paycheck or
monthly you've got a budget that you
sell that you
set for yourself and you just buy the
old stacker
the old stacker mentality is if you
don't hold it you don't own it
and that's why that's why people don't
like etfs or stackers don't like etfs
i almost forgot i never answered the
question that i asked up top
and should i buy it off an ad on tv
no just go to tv ad bullion dealers
uh i would take a look at whoever is
doing that ad
and do research on the company first
keep in mind
all that glitters isn't well you get the
idea